unser weltbild erweitert sich von tag zu
tag und das im wahrsten sinne des wortes
jetzt ist ein neuer zwerg planet in
unserem sonnensystem dazu gekommen er
könnte uns auf die spur von planet x9
bringen wie das klick zum science
fiction
hier gibt es täglich neue science videos
abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich
willkommen das gibt sich alle tage ein
neues werk planet in unserem
sonnensystem und core plänen so heißt er
ist ein ganz besonderer während pluto
seine umlaufbahn in einer entfernung von
30 bis 50 astronomischen einheiten um
die sonne zieht macht das kopplin in 65
bis acht um 2.300 astronomischen
einheiten seiner band ist so nicht nur
extrem elliptisch sondern entfernt sich
auch extrem weit von der sonne eine
astronomische einheit ist dabei die
entfernung zwischen erde und sonne
entdeckt wurde er dabei bei der suche
nach planeten respektive iks also dem
unbekannten aber vermuteten riesigen
gasplaneten weit draußen kreisen um
unsere sonnengott den wurde erstmals
2015 von einem astronomie team entdeckt
federführend waren dabei es gescheppert
und chat trio von der national
university sowie david tholen von der
university of hawaii
sie entdeckten goblin per zufall mit dem
hawaiianischen teleskop subaru nachdem
sie ihn jetzt drei jahren beobachtet
hatten und seine bahn bestimmen konnten
bestätigten sie den fund von 2015 tg 387
goblin katalogisiert wurde für seine
bahn um die sonne benötigt jetzt fährt
planet achtung rund 40.000 jahre sein
durchmesser beträgt 300 kilometer und es
ist nicht der erste zwergplanet denn bei
der suche nach planeten aufgespürt wurde
zitat wir denken dass es tausende kleine
körper wie 2015 tg 387 draußen einen
rändern unseres sonnensystems geben
könnte aber ihre entfernung macht die
entdeckung sehr schwierig so einer der
entdecker der vitol und doch diese
entfernung hat auch einen entscheidenden
vorteil diese fernen objekte sind wie
brotkrumen die uns so plane takes führen
sagt gott shepherd ihre umlaufbahn um
die sonne wird nicht von den bekannten
bewusst jede beule in ihrer bahn könnte
ein hinweis auf planet iks sein
der riesige gas plant den soll mehr als
zehn mal mehr masse als die erde haben
aufgespürte zwergplaneten die so weit
vom zentrum unseres sonnensystems
entfernt sind können so auf kleinen
tricks hindeuten und zwar im wahrsten
sinne des wortes umso mehr von ihnen
entdeckt werden und ihre umlaufbahnen
berechnet werden können desto schneller
könnte planeten aufgespürt werden
zitat je mehr wir von ihnen finden desto
besser lernen wir das äußere
sonnensystem und den möglichen planeten
kennen von dem wir glauben dass er ihre
umlaufbahnen beeinflusst eine entdeckung
die unser wissen über die evolution des
sonnensystems neu definieren würde so
scheppert wow das wird extrem spannend
mehr über planet ins oder 9 gibt es hier
dafür draufklicken planeten nachgewiesen
wenn ihr kein video zu diesem und allen
anderen dem verpassen wollt dann
abonniere ticks und vergesst die glocke
nicht und garantiert verpasst ihr kein
video über den kostenlosen whatsapp
newsletter dafür ihr klingt nicht zur
begrüßung gibt es ein kleines cooles
goody bis dann bleibt dran